[Music]
this week we've got Pinkham jewel stools
and space herpes Wow diary like what the
[ __ ] what's your pain cam so this
company created a penis camera a cut cam
oh wait what like it was a camera yes
that's a very accurate sound I used to
own a cop no is this whimpers are there
bunch of cases all over the camera lens
Oh who's this a lot of OSIS it's kind of
thirds like agua frescas yeah like
Whoville oh that just looks like a dick
ring you know like where the top
vibrates a camera to it so the your
footage is all [ __ ] shaky yeah you
could get like a close-up on the clip I
hate this
elation it could be a close-up on the
[ __ ] face dirty [ __ ] over there huh
was like she was a Fed no she was on the
face two guys on the face and it could
face this way or this way yeah
depending if I'm laying down or not come
on I mean get their leg down so you can
buy this thing for 160 dollars they say
that eventually you'll be able to
livestream it
no no we see some footage I did have
footage by deleted it because no
that's all like to promote this product
they had this dude this BASE jumper guy
I'll put it on his dick put it well
they're saying that he's wearing a
prosthetic it's like a strap-on why did
he have the base jump that's so weird
you know what does it have to do with
anything whether you did it or not we
could see if the camera works what if he
base jumped into the mouth of a girl she
laughs it was all just [ __ ] weird
advertising the whole thing yeah well I
was gonna show it to you guys but it's
just all you see is like this thing in
front of the camera as like this
beautiful scenery like a dick tip to
swinging around oh yeah like the whole
um chef chef good cause you put out the
base of the dick Oh got at the tip of it
where were you thinking no he's BASE
jumping right so I thought he would want
to get the best view and slide it to the
front of it that's true but I guess for
their marketing thing it's like this is
what to dig up their marketing is all
[ __ ] up I'm not gonna show you I don't
know I don't like POV porn it's just the
angles like I want to see angles that I
can't see but I think why people like
POV porn is because they want to pretend
that they're in it like that's them and
what about that
that's angle you can't see oh but it's
like a lot of chin or I don't know like
or nose or forehead or I don't know cuz
it's not even POV because you're doing
the point of view of a dick it's too
cold you don't to be late unless you're
the day yeah if you ever wanted to be a
dick now you take a POV PUA
yeah big point of view it could record
up to 90 minutes of 1080p and mp4 format
it also features night vision and that's
creepy have you seen night vision
eyeballs it's all green looking at cuz I
look at tiger at night
and synthesizer so open I'm a Brawley
look possessed call your son breakfast a
little bro yeah so that's the thing now
ah I don't think we thing is gonna be
insert a camera inside the body like I
call an Oscar be uh oh no that's
probably gonna be the next thing I don't
know it's like I want to zoom in even
further now then they're gonna have
x-ray porn I've seen that I've seen
something like that where it's not x-ray
there in like an MRI or something Oh
actually like see everything going on
well they're [ __ ] yeah oh that's
pretty interesting porn are you watching
also what kind of MRI machine those
things are tight I know I gotta beat I
know people
no no they meant like tight they're cool
oh no there's real tiny you get
claustrophobic more like like a little
porn it was like a cement occasionally
and I saw I came across somehow I don't
know I look at a lot of weird [ __ ] 4j
give you anything for decade news yeah
right yeah for research well how do you
think I got this job oh that's right
look at my [ __ ] search history guys I
should be the host of this show that
that's really what went down yeah pretty
much
anyway moving on to our next story so
you know how March Madness yeah is a
thing mm-hmm so what is March Madness is
it like basketball college okay yeah
so a lot of men are very dedicated
viewers of this event and so a lot of
men decide to get their vasectomies
right before March Madness so they can
stay at home that whole week Oh
that's the thing just so they could
watch college basketball yes and they
don't the good work that's Wow and 2016
urologist gave 30 percent more vasectomy
than the average week right before March
Madness reversible so they just you came
over to do it every year
women didn't know that yeah we do it
every year they get it by second meeting
at during that time of year it goes up
and they call it vac madness yeah cuz
you know how they cut the vast
difference yeah anyway so because of
that's a doctor joke tip doctors in this
room well I guess not everyone to say it
was funny they called it that to bet but
that's just like if a doctor was he said
[Laughter]
is cashing in on that trend maybe you
hated this dick wings
whoa getting a vasectomy for the
tournament
[Music]
Bart's gonna get once I start second
loan monkey for you come sit on the
jewel stool
oh I thinks it comes [ __ ] and come hang
this March that's a baby Buffalo and
even I think this is a terrible idea so
much do that Buffalo Wild Wings sucks
just it's no wings stop these thoughts
better fries with the ranch baby large
in my mouth now I like no original
flavor
hey you said wing stop but you just
refer to the fries huh yeah and I only
talk about fries okay why are you not
fat to where your pimples [ __ ] for me
to unfollow you right now do it I will
[ __ ] you now I'm just gonna meet the
post-order the grease go I want you to
know know that I care yeah where did the
grease go yeah weird she probably sweats
it all out what she's bad something [ __ ]
[ __ ] french fries [ __ ] one Shake
Shack six pimple did done done I love
this commercial commercial it's a
commercial yeah yeah I mean they're
promoting their Jules tools favorite
wing flavor now so what is it garlic
parmesan or Carly Palmer's on the way
just fried chicken we have to choose it
flavor you have to choose a flavor
garlic parmesan you just copied me but
you got wheat which is a buff but the
Buffalo is that's what a real wing is
well yeah a hot wing hot weak-eyed
that's why I like buffalo flames
that's the only thing Buffalo New York
is good for is the wings yeah yeah we
had some wings out there so good it's
good and we went to their famous place
but I still think a laundress and a
couple of other places here better
really thought it was better than
you got him like that maybe I'll be
really hungry maybe we're gonna go to
the same place but remember I mean me
and Bart went to their world famous like
it was like I thought we can stop a very
- it was it was like it was the original
Buffalo eventing restaurant oh maybe
because it was the original maybe it
wasn't the best place maybe it's where I
started oh yeah you know those two
Philly cheesesteak spots in Jena yes
supposedly there's a million dollar
better but those are just like the
originators mmm yeah that's really she's
dead now with Cheez Whiz if it's not
cheesy that's now really come I have to
come with the powder yeah but she
doesn't come from powder it's not real
don't worry oh look it's it's covered
like this that's not what she's worried
completely ignores you that's your
[ __ ] blood temperature vein pops out
oh my god yeah but yeah you're asking
what it is
yeah we're studying this so this is only
happening in Times Square and in
Koreatown LA and they're saying that
there are these certain that there are
these certain chairs that have these
like metal things at the bottom to cool
your nuts
oh yes is a oh wait it's actual jewels
then where you're supposed to put your
pear balls well that that sounds nest
now your bear balls but like just you
know if you're sitting in your pants
like it'll be cooling your nuts and then
it also cool your drink on the side it
kind of looks like an electric chair to
me refurbished electric church it would
be a better company if their wings were
crispier but they're not I like pretty
battered right a crispy I know the
flavors not bad just now crispy yeah
it's not good enough do they be better
because it tastes like baked beans to me
yeah or something like that
you know they're too soft yeah I don't
like those kind of Buffalo Engel maybe
they are bakes maybe they sent you
dropping them and fry real quick I know
look we're just [ __ ] taking this all
right
[ __ ] and then Rizal the sauce
after that's how you make real good
wings yeah I think that you'll ever get
a vasectomy life absolutely not I rather
cut off my dick you are what I think
people get vasectomy so they don't have
to condoms for the rest of their life
I'm gonna do get out there with ya I'll
rather sterilize my balls how that is
sterilizing your mom not gonna cut it
I'm just gonna [ __ ] drink a lot of
Mountain Dew or something would you take
the male birth control pills over to
them nope I rather take estrogen pills
I'll take estrogen pills in my case I
would after we have our seculow for sure
well after our second all the shots yeah
cuz condoms kind of suck yeah and then
after our second one so you're not often
worried about I don't call the shots
yeah I like condoms
we just can't make a better card on your
side and just have him sin a bit more on
this how would you do it it just needs
to be made out of some kind of space
material that's so [ __ ] thin but it
has a tensile strength of [ __ ]
platinum you know so nothing will burst
through it you know they haven't done
that yet like technology is so far
advanced but it's still like this
archaic low balloon like Japanese
companies do it really well there's one
that I was using it was called Spock
obviously I was using you can it just
told us about it well we need this
personal recommendation what is it so
it's it's it's I think it's called
Okamoto is like the company yeah it's
like Oh point zero zero three
millimeters thick yeah it feels property
yeah I've tried them already good there
can't tell oh really I think it makes it
big to me all to all them feel the same
they just suck all around well the
problem is that people have been
complaining it's like size-wise is kind
of small so it kind of suffocates a
little bit so
what happenes dick I mean I don't know I
actually like condoms because what yeah
you think oh it feels no because like I
timed everything else down to a science
some sensitive as [ __ ] so I don't want
to bus too fast yeah and then like at
the last moment I'm like Oh condom time
this is gonna add extra points to my
teeth like my [ __ ] longevity yeah so
it's like if I was playing a video game
then my health bar goes down you know
because I bought the bus right and then
you put it on and it goes right back up
and I could last a little bit longer
yeah like a significant amount longer
fight not anything anything is just you
know like that extra half second [ __ ]
cuz by that time you're like the geyser
is about to burst [ __ ] it this is this
is Yellowstone National Park
yeah ah [ __ ] up like the regular OG
condoms that are extra thick you'll feel
nothing poor Jess it sucks with a girl
too though yeah yeah they don't feel
anybody they just feel like a big old
plastic thing in there yeah might as
well just be a dildo right no all right
filled now still know might as well just
be something right I'm not a girl I
don't know how I'm just saying things
though man spleen in this circle okay
dude what's mansplain again I don't know
some [ __ ] alright alright so for our
last story tests have shown that dormant
herpes viruses reactivates and are
reactivated in more than half of the
astronauts who traveled on the space
shuttle and the space International
Space Station so you have so much for
babies they're saying that during
spaceflight there's a rise and secretion
of stress hormones like cortisol and
adrenaline and those are known to
suppress the immune system so not
talking about like STD harpies your time
I just like cold sores like that Gaza
they just call it herpes herpes are a
form of STDs it's just people
don't really think about it like that
just because like it's not lethal it's
not deadly nothing can happen to you
from it just like simple X 1 & 2 outside
in size I think just a ret even a
regular cold circuit it's called herpes
yeah yeah the the thing that you have
here and your general it's the same
thing so and like what the [ __ ] did my
my doctor buddy told me that it just
canker sores but not cool that's not
that's not it
that's something different is it ways
use the on your lip I've never ever had
that so most people I heard it was like
I heard a lot of Asian people have it
because we we share a lot of food so you
know so a lot of people have like herpes
like dormant within them it's like it's
like a ridiculous time right you can
have it without being sexually active -
yeah like it could be passed down from
your parents or they kiss you they drink
or drink check I could be wrong but he
told me like some number of like 75% of
the world has some form of herpes yeah
it was like super tiny it's like
basically being sick is what I've heard
like everyone's like like when you get a
cold it's like that's when your herpes
would be I'm here and when it's not you
still have it but you wouldn't see it
hey guys I'm in and sexually like in
sexually active people it's like 1 out
of 5 or something yeah yeah really high
Jessica Alba has that all right so
you're okay people
you're okay people so what about these
astronauts they like make out with each
other all day mm-hmm Publishing this
recently in the journal frontiers in
microbiology and they were just saying
how NASA astronauts
that's a NASA team so they're like weeks
or even months exposed to microgravity
and cosmetic radiation and so they have
also extreme g-forces of takeoff and
reentry dish whoa
chief change the forces and then so
they're saying that like all of that is
compounded to be stressors and then of
just like bring up that dormant that
sounds stressful as oh yeah totally
yeah so out of 89 astronauts that they
studied only six experienced herpes in
space which is herpes in space sounds
like a movie yeah
that's like a rate of about 7% it's
pretty high yeah yeah damn that's crazy
herpes in space Coulter suck dude what
do you think they do all day in space
[ __ ] all day like all on the way there
isn't like a long time yeah what you
gonna do I don't know they gotta like
man the ship and come always send signal
reports there's reports and stuff the
whole time you downplay what a astronaut
does asking a question more friend right
cuz I don't know for me
that's what I hate about this generation
is we all want ask for friends don't be
ashamed of what you don't know yeah I'm
asking for a friend
but herpes I hope they have Netflix or
something yep they're working but they
can't be working all the time I wonder
if they're working like non-stop or do
they go I'm off my shift it's been eight
hours and there's government rules in
the shade other shifts there's probably
cuz I mean I'm equating it to my
submarine life which I know nothing
about final so I think it's posit that
what they probably have well they have
stations and they're probably Manning it
for certain shifts and people can get
off and then they can go and like work
out yeah and then or like have
entertainment time I just picture them
taking a pee and then just everyone like
whoa and then like the actually have to
suck the pee out
oh god hey look at backing out I wonder
if it feels good Wow Joe has a lot of us
potty-trained are you still peeing
[Laughter]
[Music]